So in more general terms, why do we want to
use object orientation? The first reason is that object
orientation can help reduce long-term maintenance costs by limiting
the effects of changes. As we saw, the effect
of using encapsulation and information hiding makes it easier
to modify parts of the system without affecting the
rest of the system. Object orientation can also improve
the developing process by favoring code and design reuse.
In general, object orientation helps
enforcing good design principles. Principles such
as the ones that we saw in encapuslation, information hiding, high
cohesion, low coupling and we will discuss these aspects more extensively
in the next mini course which is centered around design concepts.